marc alter eco notre correspondante est
en direct à moscou bonsoir tamarins et
raphaël jeune créatrice pour la
perspective à washington vous êtes à
montréal bonsoir raphaël bonsoir tamara
je commence avec vous parce que la
maison blanche dès qu'ils ont entendu ce
point de presse des américains
washington en fin d'après midi
aujourd'hui on dit qu est-ce qu il passe
il s'énerve encore pour rien existe
ce qu'on attend du doigt washington
syrien que vous et moi en tant que
journaliste pouvons vérifier et patrice
elle se base sur des nouvelles
informations de son propre service de
renseignement des informations qui ont
été coulés d'abord à des journalistes et
qui comme vous l'avez dit décrit un
scénario qui dans l'échelle des
scénarios qu'on appréhende depuis des
mois et le pire
on parle même de tirer deux missiles sur
kiev pour y installer un nouveau régime
donc c'est sûr qu'on a demandé à james
harden qui est le conseiller aux à la
ccry net à la sécurité nationale qu'est
ce qui vous fait dire que ce scénario
est non seulement plus osée mais éminent
ne pas voulu donner de détails mais
washington est maintenant le canada on
viens de l'entendre à ottawa aussi
demande à tous ses ressortissants de
sortir d'ukraine c'est vraiment souffre
qui peut on leur donne 24 à 48 heures
pour le faire parce qu'on dit que la
taxe pourrait survenir la semaine
prochaine avant la fin des jeux
olympiques
on peut écouter là-dessus jigsaw
donc c'est la nuit ici à moscou patrice
mais il ya quelques heures une porte
parole du kremlin a réagi pour dire que
c'est révélateur que les ans je la cite
les anglo saxons ont besoin d'une guerre
à tout prix donc on voit de la
propagande de guerre mais c'est sûr
qu'il se passe quelque chose on nous a
confirmé un monsieur peskov le porte
parole de poutine que le président russe
va s'entretenir demain au téléphone à
11h heure de montréal avec joe biden on
nous avait dit patrice que la prochaine
fois que les présidents à laisse parler
de vive voix c'est parce que ça en
vaudra la peine donc faut croire que ça
en vaut la peine mais est ce que c'est
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire c'est
qu'on sait c'est ce qu'on s'est pas à ce
stade on rappelle tamara qu'il ya un
bras de fer qui se joue on va voir la
carte la russie ne veut absolument pas
qu'un jour l'ukraine fasse son entrée
dans le tas ne veut pas impayés dans l
de l'autre quant à ses portes tous les
pays en bleu on l'avait longuement
expliqué l'autre fois on le rappelle
fonds sont membres de l'otan la rue
poutine je joue une grosse partie de
poker en ligne est pas question que
l'ukraine décide d'aller vers le temps
et fait des pressions auprès de
washington pour que washington fasse que
ça n'arrive jamais or les troupes russes
autour de l'ukraine sont bel et bien
hélas tamara ça fait partie des
renseignements américains il ya eu ces
photos satellites y en a eu d'autres
récemment ou est loin des tentes
habitées qui n'étaient pas habitées ya
quelques mois donc moscou continuent de
masser des troupes à la frontière là
quand même
oui et pas seulement en ukraine du nord
au sud de la crimée jusqu'au jusqu'au
nord mais aussi au bélarus qui lui donne
une porte d'entrée de plus sur l'ukraine
moscou s'est jamais cachée d'avoir des
troupes et maintient que ce sont des
exercices militaires
précisément combien yacht soldats on le
sait pas on parle de 130000 mais c'est
pas juste les soldats qui sont
importants c'est l'artillerie qu'ils ont
avec eux
chi chi chi qui porte à croire en tout
cas du côté de washington que la taxe
serait imminente et les méthodes
mentionné
serait serait très plausible mais ce qui
est étonnant dans ce conte entendre
washington aujourd'hui que c'est ça
arrive au terme d'une semaine quand même
diplomatique ou poutine reçoit plus les
foules à ce qu'on voit à moscou l'on n'a
jamais vus poutine recevoir autant de
dignitaires étrangers y compris pays de
l'est pour des discussions diplomatiques
y compris le président macron des
discussions au thème après lesquels on
ne sait pas que tout était réglé
certainement pas mais on nous disait
qu'il y avait encore espoir pour la
diplomatie sauf que le problème reste
que poutine n'a pas ce qu'il veut et les
américains veulent pas lui de lui donner
donc on est on reste dans une impasse
oui ce thème jeunes parce que
effectivement après la rencontre avec ma
cromback ronde est bon c'est pas réglé
mais on sent quand même un apaisement là
la discussion se poursuit or raphaël à
l'origine de tout ça c'est que
washington ne donne pas au kremlin ce
que poutine veut c'est à dire
l'assurance de washington que jamais dû
craindre ferait un globe et dans le
temps exactement un terme arabe y est
tellement de bien l'expliquer c'est à
dire que le noeud de cette crise là il
faut toujours le rappeler c'est la
question de l'otan on se parle de
diplomatie de haut niveau le connu cette
semaine je vous donne une autre
rencontre lui parle d'une autre
rencontre ait lieu entre le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères monsieur
la brave et la secrétaire d'état
britannique
tamara utilisait le terme anglo saxon
tantôt la libye tonique et les
américains sera essentiellement sur la
même longueur d'onde ne sera pas partout
depuis le début et en sortant de cette
rencontre là je vous cite ce que
monsieur là bravo dit il a dit j'ai eu
l'impression de rencontrer une sourde
une personne sourde était là mais elle
entend des riez et sa patte rieuse je
sais moi même de le répéter à l'émission
depuis maintenant des semaines les
américains et ne pouvez insérer les
britanniques en parenthèse n'écoute rien
n'est que je ne vous dis pas qu'il
devrait céder puisque je vous dis c'est
que depuis le début on dit à washington
qu on fait de la diplomatie qu'on fait
des compromis mais on offre des choses
qui me l'a dit mais personne ne veut pas
ou tout au moins qu'il ne veut pas
partie l'erm ce que lui ce qui le
dérange profondément et ce depuis des
années c'est la question de l'otan est
là dessus les américains et leurs alliés
sont d'une intransigeance totale depuis
le début donc c'est pas pour rien qu'on
se retrouve dans une impasse de la sorte
c'est que d'un côté on demande quelque
chose de hyper précis et de l'autre côté
on refuse catégoriquement de céder sur
cette même chose et on ne dit pas que on
va encourager l'ukraine à faire partie
de l'otan mais on dit l'ukraine comme
pays indépendant ciel voulait un jour
rejoindre l'otan ben il empêchera pas
c'est ça la réponse américaine en fait
c'est là qu'il faut remonter dans le
temps c'est que c'est la réponse est
actuel présentement mais si vous vous
mettez dans la peau de poutine et que
vous regardez le gouvernement américain
dans son ensemble c'est ce même
gouvernement la même s'ils étaient
dirigées par d'anciens présidents
notamment le président bush pour pas
leur cité ont déjà tendu des perches
beaucoup plus explicite en dix ans
peut-être que ce serait une très bonne
idée en fait que l'ukraine se joignent à
l'otan pas tenir la georgie et fera donc
d'une perspective russe je peux jouer le
rôle tamara mais ça fait des années
qu'on a ce sentiment là et cette crainte
là il faut la comprendre il faut aussi
la comprendre et à washington
cette compréhension là semble pour le
moins peu défaillante exxon tamara vous
l'avez dit c'est intéressant parce que
poutine se retrouve au centre d'un jeu
de poker international donc il prend peu
importe le dénouement il prend de la
force il veut et si ce qu'il plaît dit
ce qu'il veut depuis des années il veut
redevenir un joueur incontournable
mais ça il est devenu il est devenu
depuis longtemps je pense que le jour il
a annexé la crime et contre toute
attente alors que tout le monde
regardait ailleurs je pense qu'il sert
et imposer comme pau comme grande
puissance parce qu'économiquement l'est
la russie et pour un grand joueur mais
comme comme grande puissance
géopolitique avec beaucoup d'influx ans
il ya deux lieux deux écoles de pensée
moi je suis je baigne beaucoup dans les
analyses
vu de la russie est la question qui se
pose en ce moment bon d'abord si c'est
un jeu qui soit initiée par les
américains il a réussi c'est un jeu
hyper dangereux oui on peut dire jamais
de mes soldats à la frontière le temps
d'en déploie d'autres en pologne c'est
pour faire monter les enchères mais ça
prend pas grand-chose
pour une bavure pour une provocation ça
c'est des risques réels la question
qu'on se pose maintenant poutine il
l'obtiendra pas ce par écrit que
l'ukraine ne peut pas être membre de
l'otan si on le lui accorde va falloir
trouver une façon plus originale de le
lui garantir
c'est qu'à kehl pas partir de quel
moment poutine la tête au pot peut
reculer ses troupes sans perdre la face
que ce qui plaît
qu'est-ce qui peut dire qu'est ce que
j'ai gagné je pense que vu d'où je suis
avec les russes avec lesquels je vis
depuis déjà 4 à je pense que s'il recule
sans attaquer il perd pas il
n'est pas perdant dans la mesure où y'a
aucun appétit ici pour une attaque en
tout cas certainement pas comme elle est
décrite aujourd'hui par washington sur
l'ukraine ça écarte pas par contre est
le fou surveiller ça le dôme basse l'est
de l'ukraine c'est compliqué c'est lourd
comme conflit à décrire et expliquer
mais il ya une guerre chaude qui se joue
là bas entre l'ukraine et des
séparatistes des ukrainiens aimé qu'ils
sont soutenus par moscou et ça peut être
aussi une porte d'entrée pour une
invasion de vladimir poutine en ukraine
aller croquer un morceau ce qui avait
fait dire à joe biden hérisson déjà là
ouais ce serait là les r6 il prend
qu'une
une miette une petite bouche et on fera
rien on va reparler mais c'est très
éclairant de vous entendre altérer ce qu
en direct de moscou serviette en pleine
nuit je le rappelle raphaël jacob à
montréal en début de soirée vous merci à
vous deux et on en reparle on
surveillera suspendu olympique salut